Here's an actual pedigree tracking bipolar disorder in an
Amish family. Now at first glance, you may think that
this looks pretty familiar, and may make you feel right
at home. But like many complex traits, this pedigree looks
different than it would for a single-gene disorder. For
example, if I told you to look at this pedigree
and tell me if you thought the inheritance pattern was
dominant or recessive. You might be inclined to say dominant,
if you look at the fact that the
trait doesn't skip generations and affected parents do give
rise to affected children. But you might also think
that it's recessive. For example over here the trait
skipped generations. And it did over here as well.
And we have unaffected parents with affected children. That's
typical of a recessive trait. We're actually somewhere in
between. This is complex. Now to me, this pedigree
indicates a more dominant inheritance pattern. Now if we
assume the trait to be dominate like we learned
about in lesson five and completely penetrant right, that's
the only kind we've talked about up to this
point. Then we would expect affected children to have
at least one affected parent. But that's not what
we saw. What we see are unaffected parents. If
you thought the trait looks more recessive, we wouldn't expect
it to show up in every generation like it did here. These little
deviations from our normal inheritance patterns
are a key indicator that there are
likely multiple genetic factors, as well
as environmental factors, controlling the phenotype. Whenever
we find incompletely penetrant traits or
alleles, this is likely what's going on.